all right Ashley and Andrew yes Ashley
and Andrew you guys are brother sister
and brother twins your twins yes oh and
you grew up in Ohio we were born in Ohio
Akron Ohio I interviewed Ashley four
years ago at least you were one of the
very first people I interviewed down
here yep and uh your story can be
found somewhere on my channel but what
interests me is is so you guys
are both using yes right yeah what are
your drugs currently on and off no I
mean yeah I'm doing myth right now and
Fentanyl and mine yeah yeah Fentanyl and
crack yeah yeah actually you've been
down here quite a while
almost eight years eight years yeah
Xander you're not living on the streets
or are you yeah I'm living on the
streets currently in my me and my
girlfriend in the car like well we're
just day to day like you know try to
work and do doordash
we don't have a place now yeah
um
but uh uh I'm trying my best to do
things right you know try to at least
maintain a somewhat uh normal life and
after getting out of prison oh you're in
prison yeah yeah
eight years I got out October what was
that for uh for a strong robbery
um and in prison I I got caught up for
attempted murder on another inmate yeah
so tell me about your childhoods you uh
your parents oh okay uh what
um our parents had us uh when they were
young our well pretty young my mom was
19 my dad was 18.
and everything was cool
um until we were about three years old
my dad started using heroin and you know
stealing my mom's money
um you know for
groceries diapers and stuff like that
so my mom
left him my dad's my grandma got my dad
on um
crack and heroin because she was uh
getting high and she wanted somebody she
wanted you know he was working he was
doing construction or whatever she
wanted someone to you know pay for her
drugs she died she did Memaw no not man
my grandma Grandma
Debbie Grandma Debbie Grandma Debbie
mamaw
she died last year they gave her Narcan
uh or something you know they gave her
Narcan and she would she hit a parked
car in Ohio
um when I was in prison my uncle called
me and you let me know that they
gnarkander because I thought she was
oding she's like the past and she was
just asleep
um anyway and they killed her yeah yeah
so it killed her no I didn't know that
anyway let's enter into the [__]
anyway well she got my dad hooked and so
my dad was stealing money from my mom
and um my mom just left him and then she
met my stepdad who was like you know
rude or with like picnics and all you
know showered her with all these things
and
um he was a psycho though uh he got my
mom pregnant and you like he would like
drug her and uh did she hide her birth
control pills and um she doesn't
remember her wedding we went to Las
Vegas and she got married she doesn't
remember it and yeah he doesn't know he
doesn't remember a lot of things like I
remember I remember I guess you know I
was maybe paying more attention
yeah I'm one minute younger but I'm a
girl I was I was like the girl the only
girl really because my mom had another
son with my stepdad we're talking about
right now and so it's just the two boys
there you know and me so
I would kind of probably my mom probably
like
I don't know maybe vented to me a little
bit uh so I knew what was going on a
little more than he did and uh
yeah so then um they would always get
invites and stuff
um I remember the cops coming to our
house all the time all the time the cops
are coming to our house and then social
workers were coming to our house and
stuff and we'd be hiding
um me and my mom my brother would be
hiding
in my mom's room when they come to the
door
and uh avoiding them so this was the
last time though that uh
yeah the last time that the cops came
uh
actually
was when they came to because they take
uh us away so that was after that my mom
got hit by with um they said it was that
I don't know why my mom said tell them
that spaghetti Bowl slipped out of him
slapped your drawers anyway it was an
ashtray she got hit in the mouth with an
ashtray and it cut over her lip right
here and I don't know what I told school
about it I remember it was all bloody
and [__] we ran to the minivan and we
went down the street my my grandma and
my dad the one I talked about that were
on drugs lived down the street so my mom
we drove down there I just remember my
stepdad holding a big rock like he was
gonna throw it at the house you remember
that yeah and then um yeah so then we
got to my grandma's house and then um I
was good at like keeping secrets and
stuff Andrew could never lie he could
never lie he always started laughing or
like when my stepdad would say did you
guys see your dad today
uh because my dad would come over when
he's at work and I know I see my mom
smoking weed um because I remember like
spying on her and seeing what were they
doing are they kissing or something you
know but uh we play Spy and but they my
dad had like a bag of weed I remember
when I'm seeing this green bag and um
they'd just be smoking weed they're like
Stoners and um Mighty stuffed out come
from work and say did you guys see yours
see your dad today and I'd be like no my
brother would be like you're kind of
you're gonna hold it back like you're
gonna lie for anything so it's a good
call yeah he told the school nurse what
happened and next thing you know like
these social worker came and picked us
up from school and took us to the um to
the whatever the department of DCFS DCFS
building and uh my mom was there holding
my little brother and um he was two
years old at the time he just passed
away in March
um from a fentanyl accidental overdose
and um Marshall I said and um
yeah so
that was when we went to a fosterone
which is horrible it's the worst place
ever we really endured some abuse there
um
especially Andrew he did he had a lot of
abuse they abused him a lot they were
Jehovah's Witnesses and um the the
mankind have sexually abused me he never
touched me but he would tell me like
weird stuff and had me like lay on his
lap and I wanted to do chores like I
told my mom I want to do chores and my
mom would like let me like you know I
put a balloon in my stomach when my mom
was pregnant pretended I was like my mom
you know when I lived with my mom it was
a good life like my mom never made us
feel bad ever like
she really like you know loved treated
us with love we never abused by her ever
our stepdad kind of gave us like a cold
like cold shoulder like kind of like
treated us a little bit cold your
biological dead no our stepdad yeah my
brother my logical dad
organs like uh six months into our us
being Foster he overdosed because uh
I guess my stepdad had called him over
and said I have some good [__] um
you want to try it or something and um I
stepped at him and my dad went over
there and it was a hot shot and he was
dead he died in our bedroom
and our stepdad's house when we were in
foster care my mom was uh
my mom I guess she was already like uh
kind of like she was traumatized from us
losing us that my stepdad was pissed
because she was running around getting
high she started getting high she
started doing like lines of coke and
then she was smoking crack and uh I
guess that's probably why he was so mad
and had my dad come over there and um
and
give him a shot killed him
because he was pissed about my mom
um you know Mom like their dad better
yeah
but yeah uh something might be like a
few years do you guys feel like what you
went through as the children or why
you're in the situation you're in today
yeah not having a strong Foundation or
and not having yeah absolutely
definitely yeah if we were yeah if we
had a different life I don't think our
family certain people in our family who
you know chose to take on certain
responsibilities and then decide to back
away from him last minute things like
that I guess he's talking about our
grandma but I don't feel like that way
I'm saying what I'm saying so anyway uh
you can get in my bag that's fine
uh so
yeah we were there for a while I know
that they Andrew I remember one time oh
he actually opened up the door he's a
German Shepherd they had two German
Shepherds who had shock collars on but
um I was playing with this one girl in
the in the front yard she was like the
dog didn't know her right and she was on
our property and my brother opened up
the door we knew we weren't supposed to
open the door right but anyways around
and the dog ran out and bit the girl's
arm and she had to get like 16 stitches
they had to put the dog down and ever
since then our foster dad really had
like hated Andrew no I hated you hated
him and I remember he had to sit like
it's like yeah it's 20 hours and [__] no
like for like a month he had to stand
like yeah in the corner and then it was
his arm up you guys remember it felt
unreal okay I'll tell you what happened
he was sitting on at the table facing
the windows housewife six yeah
he was sitting up there like the
the dining room table
not facing the table but facing the
window and this is what I remember so
stop I'm the one facing the corner right
well I'm the one who remember seeing you
there [__] you man
anyways you're in the corner me too I
understand the car until I threw up in
front of the heater they do like weird
[__] and then we didn't then they didn't
even tell us that like we want to be
having holidays we didn't know like
to pop up any minute now like
is everybody's gonna drop my best job
any minute now and they didn't even say
anything about it so it was pretty
traumatizing in a way two years like
that yeah like being little innocent
kids and she kicked me out three months
later
like three to six months she kept her
until she's 13.
that's not true
I'm [__] uh it's very true
[__] I stay in group homes for All
Those Years anyway so I went back into a
foster home um from 10 11 to 12.
in case you didn't know I'm Whittier
with sage you don't know what I did so
stop we're on video here and you're
trying to tell you tell your story I'll
tell mine eleven twelve really uh-huh it
was a nice foster home Richard no no no
no no no no in Whittier with Regina and
Jeff I remember that yeah yeah yeah that
wasn't a nice one only like a year now
that was three years
those three years I remember score we
remember things differently yeah this is
why when people threw these videos on my
Channel people say oh he's so-and-so is
lying right because you have a version
of the story you were right next to her
and you have a totally different story
yeah mom or dad would have a totally
different story right it's just I guess
this point in front of you anyway so
then when I had my bot Mitzvah my
grandma she um took me back
um because she didn't like how she saw
my foster mom was like trying was just
the way that she was acting she just uh
when she was at my mom's my grandma paid
for and through she just didn't like the
energy coming from her because she just
like sat in the corner all weird and
like just kind of I don't know just very
weird uh with my whole family so my
grandma took me back and then
I was so happy to come back
um
but uh
yeah then I started um that's when I
started kind of acting out
um in Middle School kind of like
kind of like dressing like [__] and uh
hanging out with
wanting to do things fast wanting to
yeah and start doing drugs
um
in eighth grade I started trying
um to get
um I don't know just a different little
like I try to get cocaine and um my
Grandma had found out about it because
uh
I don't know somebody told on me and um
I think my school counselor we told her
my school counselor everything it's so
much there's so much there's so so much
I can't put it all into one into one of
them like session right here but um
yeah so I was 15 I just when I was from
all that time from eight to five eight
to basically
14 13 I was in group homes I started
running away like 14. and uh then I
started uh going going in all the
direction uh and I ended up juvenile
halls for two years and the next thing
you know after that um from juvenile
Halls it was uh County Jail to prison I
ended up doing prison basically up until
last year I've been locked up like some
way or another yeah no more than two or
three months out in six months in Mexico
or something like that but it was always
quick you know yeah how old are you guys
29 29 29 yeah you're still young did you
guys have hope of straightening out your
lives a bit getting off the streets
getting yeah I had a lot of
opportunities that like most people
wouldn't have like
um like after that they happened my
grandma tried to put me in a group home
that's when she put in a group home and
I ran away from like 32 different group
homes that you just couldn't stay on
them and um
I had a big sister a Jewish big sister
and uh
uh she uh
put like an ad in like the Jewish uh you
know
um newsletter or something
saying that I needed a home and um a
wealthy
um really good family um took me in
and even there I looked it off when I
went out I took ecstasy I came back on
ecstasy and then my father's mom stayed
up all night talking to me on ecstasy
and she was they were so cool they were
really well off and um spoiled me and it
was just it really really could have
been a really great life really great
life for me um but I messed it up trying
to go too fast and uh
we went to South Carolina for um I'm
leaning board went to South Carolina
um
Myrtle Beach and uh for the summer and I
snuck out I was getting drunk and
hanging out with like these three guys
from Canada I didn't do anything with
them but still I was getting drunk and
you know they don't know what I did or
didn't do so to them it looked really
bad
and then um so I was going to a a school
called um shall have it which is like a
twenty thousand dollar uh Jewish school
so they paid my tuition which is
non-refundable and um we're going to
summer Retreat this summer The Freshman
Retreat like it's right before school
starts
and when I was there they had called a
like geek Geek Squad or something to
come um hack my computer if you get into
my Facebook to see what was going on
because
um
one of our family members uh knew I was
getting drunk and sneaking and and she
she told I mean uh which to her brother
which was my foster dad and she was an
ex-alcoholic and I was sharing a room
with her at the house at the beach house
so she snitched on me and uh when I came
back they told me we know everything you
did
and then my foster dad called me a [__]
and I got so like offended and hurt
because that was like the only real
father figure I ever had like I felt you
know and it really hurt me so um
I like went to the bathroom and I like
try to cut my wrists and um
and I made 51.50 to me and then they
came and told me that would be coming
back home
so yeah after that I was just on the Run
um doing a lot of ecstasy all kinds of
drugs
um I never really prostituted or
anything when I was young like that but
um surprised I didn't I'm like I guess I
had like a
I don't know Angel looking out for me or
whatever because um I was really really
lucky nothing happened to me
nothing dangerous happened to me until
later on when I was uh
18.
um I got um kidnapping story you told me
kidnapped yeah and say 19. for four days
but yeah um
yeah and so I was working down here for
seven years but I've been two years not
working the streets anymore so I I don't
prostitute anymore but
yeah that's pretty much
how it how it went did you have kids no
no kids no kids no I'm lucky I'm well
done I want kids but not I'm so glad I
haven't had them
because I I mean I wouldn't be able to
live with a guilt of being out here on
drugs and doing this and that and
abandoning my kids
so I'm half you know I tried to get
pregnant before and stuff so I'm glad it
didn't work out
but I do want kids one day and Andrew
you're
I shouldn't have kids now okay
so I mean I suppose there's a lot
different possibilities
but I don't know
yeah he wants kids one day yeah I have
some kids eventually I mean I've tried a
few times and I've left the women out
with I don't I don't know you know like
if you women lie you know they say that
a lot of them said that they were
pregnant and stuff but yeah for sure
they weren't they were they're [__]
they can't even they could even get
pregnant like that's the thing like it
would like
so yeah we're using now
um he got out and I didn't want him to
um
to be doing he just showed up at my spot
which is um right here on skid row and
um
I have you know I had drugs everywhere
and stuff he just showed up out of the
blue and I was so oh I couldn't tell my
brother like after I'd seen him for
eight years
like you can't come in or I don't want
to see you and so they were drugs were
everywhere
because I don't want to get you high I
didn't want to get I knew that he's my
twin and I know yeah I got a little high
one I know that if he's gonna he's gonna
do what I'm gonna do so I was hoping
that when he got out this is my plan
before he got out
to not have anything out and not have
you know not too expose them to that but
he was telling me he's gonna go do it
somewhere else if I don't [__] it if I
can you just not talk while I'm talking
can you come you would be able to cut
that out right okay yeah you're gonna
cut out whatever I asked too if it's
about me
do you guys have hopes of getting clean
one day yeah I want to get clean now I'm
pretty clean like I I haven't been doing
the federal as much I want to get
cleaned out so I did it a couple times
but mostly it's just like meant to stay
awake so I can work and things like that
yeah we I smoke a lot of Bud my grandma
said she'll um no I found out about it
I'm again or something and my grandma
said that she'll take me excuse me right
anyway I don't know what it is Andrew
but I know that it gets people off
um supposed to get people off heroin so
my grandma said that
she'll come up with half the money for
me it was like ten thousand dollars like
she'll come up with half the money and I
can work and then I'll do the treatment
there and work off the other
um half of it in Mexico it sounds like a
really cool thing but it'll be a nice
plan sounds like a great plan but I
don't know enough about it but it's kind
of scary
yeah sounds like a tree rude like I
really like [__] like somewhere in
the jungle you know it's supposed to
like help you like it it's like kind of
like a like it makes you like
hallucinating I didn't know about that
yeah nothing scary than just smoking
fentanyl no that's true though that's
true like I guess well you know it's
worth a shot right yeah I would I mean I
was a bigger situation yeah so have you
heard about it yeah I've heard of it
yeah so yeah you know but yeah so that's
where we're at now
we got more we gotta do another one man
we got a bunch more stuff man yeah we
might have to redo it some of this huh
so tell me one more crazy story
it kind of has to go in and like order
but like
um you just pick one crazy one out of
your childhood
um okay let's see
when I was younger oh yeah when I was
younger before I went to prison I do
know halls I uh I was burglarizing a lot
of houses and stuff oh yeah and uh a lot
I had a lot yeah I hit a couple cops
houses I hit one in Torrance yeah I went
with him before he had me um he would
ring the doorbell and he hit so many
houses every day they called him Robin
Hood they called him Robin Hood in the
neighborhood that's giving everybody
free [__] he was like a really bad ass
[__] gold bars and [__] all types
of gold jewelry [__] safes guns
[__] but um one day he had um he
showed me what he does he would like
ring the doorbell and if nobody's there
he would go in one when I went with him
now one day someone was in the shower he
still went in there he
that's right part of the reason why he
was gone so long because after he hit
the cops house
um
they just did the fingerprint they
actually you know got fingerprints they
called and got prints done and then um
yeah I saw his gun they had me as Arvin
dangerous so I was like going around
like everywhere instead of getting
chases getting away yeah and there were
30 choices they were using him like um
the gang there was using him because he
was like good at doing that [__]
so they would get them all messed up on
meth and have him do these missions and
[__] and um
yeah you'd have to run from the cops
he'd always get away he would be like
jumping out of like Motel Windows drive
you through backyards you know he was
really really really lucky and really um
yeah it was cool it was not cool but it
was pretty cool how he you
I always get away you get away with like
a movie like an action movie like some
Jackie Chan they turned they did a Safe
Surrender where they gave me weed
brownies I did a safer Center Safe
Surrender in San Pedro and they raided
the house all of Harbor division
surrounded the whole place
and I just got in a Chase with heart
with rodano Beach borderline redundant
Beach Torrance uh Lomita sheriffs and I
got like two traces three dishes in one
day it was amazing it was amazing
getting away yeah I jumped through
three-story garbage shoot from Bristols
Bristol Farms into the garbage yeah like
an adrenaline rush or something that
would just get just gone yeah boom
jumping the card still motorcycle
[__] follow her face that's right
crazy yeah I just I'm not getting caught
I was so scared that he was gonna die
like it get killed by somebody going to
their house or or the cops going after
him should kill him and drugs was the
reason you're doing all that this is one
of them yeah and we were homeless we
were homeless teenagers
we were 16 years old and I really just
gave [__] away like it was crazy we were
16 years old 500 bucks and then give
away 50 000 watch like our mom was on
crack just crazy yeah like drugs so we
didn't have anybody no no I'm not even
kidding like on the Bible you know
huh all right Ashley and Andrew thank
you so much for sharing some of your
stories thank you I wish you guys lots
of luck thank you try the Bible game
thank you